demandez aujourd'hui en ce sens pour une
nouvelle vidéo comme la dernière fois je
vous ai demandé sur twitter de donner
plein de leurs voix là je me réserve le
droit d'exécuter celui-ci dû dire non à
celui ci est c'est parti on commence
voilà on n'est pas là pour apprendre à
faire du cupcake manger une banane ou
ralentit alors j'ai absolument pas ce
que ça peut donner mais j'ai tout de
même acheté mon petit lot de bananes à
temps parce que tes cheveux l'ouvrir
mais là c'est juste le bouchon à la
banane
je suis une pas même qu'ils peuvent
s'écouler c'est parti le ralenti qui tue
[Musique]
c'est lui la chiers suivant la jumbo jet
de banane qua non s'adresse pas imite la
lienne je pense que tu parles de la
lienne d'alien isolation le jeu est en
fait je moi j'ai fait leur blocage sur
ses jambes wajeha me semble que les
petites deux jambes des cuisses de
poulet quoi ou d'agneau je sais pas vous
avez une sorte de poulet qui a mangé je
sais pas moi un peu trop de bananes par
exemple passer car mon rib simule une
crise cardiaque et fait en sorte que one
s'en aperçoive je crois que je fais un
arrêt cardiaque
en fait tu t'emballes estelle quoi
jusqu'au réalisé là j'ai presque envie
de faire une séance de sport comme ça
fait un équilibre sur sa chaise
vous savez c'est un souvenir très
douloureux je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
faut qu'on prenne notre revanche
papa papa
ben c'est pas stable oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] je fais redresseurs adapté
dans un coffre d'une voiture je vais
comme ça comme aux us c'est scandaleux
hockey en carrière et je tourne je
tourne level up niveau supérieur autant
sur la chaîne regardée aux plats aux
plats jette ton téléphone sur le
plancher qu'est ce que c'est que ce
délire de jeter c'est son téléphone
comme ça j'ai pas de plancher je fais
comment sur la moquette sur le lit sur
ma chaise sur john bost ou même s'ils
ont dû plancher parce qu'on fait journée
fais-toi la pire coupe possible en
direct ce qu'il ya vraiment besoin de
toucher à quelque chose non montre nous
comment tu fais de la gym une vieille
roue dégueulasse forte ton chat sur la
tête à la manière des reculs au [ __ ]
on va tester d'éthique allait rendre un
petit service
yes we talk y avait sur et le monde y
aura donc plus éthique nous sommes
marqués ojiambo bien beau non tu as un
peu lourde pour tout étranger croquettes
appel cyprien en masque effet dû croire
que tu es françois hollande
enfin je vais pouvoir vous montrer mes
talents au canular téléphonique on
l'appelle jeunes et les bois oui bonjour
monsieur c'est françois hollande
vous allez pas me juger d'habitude à
chaque fois ok pour ta prochaine vidéo
qui sera à leur j'espère pourriture
gaubert flamby et ben écoute je vais
apprendre ça c'est marrant qu'on pose
cette question parce que j'ai toujours
vu des gens vont gober les flambées et
c'est un délire un peu bizarre moi j'ai
absolument jamais essayé de le faire un
plat ok ça a l'air tellement beau mais
je comprends pourquoi le bloc elle
vivait de gober ce truc de ouf lambicchi
fait du patinage artistique
je stresse un peu ce père mon frère
honneur partie de l'album a été ignoble
[Applaudissements]
publié un tweet roulante à tête sur ton
clavier à temps mais je vais carrément
me taper la honte devant tous les
abonnés mais bon ok
[Musique]
houba vous avez vu ce que ça a écrit
c'est d'ordre quand même le hasard umit
harry potter en disant expecto patronyme
mdr excusez moi vous êtes harry potter
oui c'est bien moi
hebron la baguette un mikado la dernière
fois c'était toi mais tu crois pas trop
monter n'appartient pas à la tête de con
s'ils présentent des sites web it sur le
front cap ou pas cap situ le fait un big
boi sinon une big merde
oh non je veux être une big bird tm fois
je vais dessiner une fleur et ça va
donner une [ __ ]
en fait c'est parce que l'image à
l'inversé on tellement tu fais que je
comprends pas trop et c'est une fleur
qu'est ce qui se passe je veux dessiner
un truc ça donne l'opposé et si on
décide un mec nu extrêmement moche sur
mon front fait de ton chien youtuber bon
de manger un deuxième tout petit service
a demandé hier un bond de 7 seulement
mais aujourd'hui je danse
mais c'est dans ce que me les haines ce
cher et c'est la fin de la vidéo en
personne ne s'y attendait mais flex
comme d'habitude si ce genre de vidéo
spéciale vous plaît n'hésitez pas à
l'aimer et puis on se retrouve très vite
dans une nouvelle vidéo
en attendant je vous invite à mettre
votre chat sur votre tête comme hercule
un passif de chalais farouche ça risque
d'être un peu dangereux jeu pas
responsables merci d'avoir regardé vous
êtes top vous serez pas encore longtemps
j'en suis sûr qu'à tours
oui
[Musique]